um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi tal
hi siobhan
thank you for joining me for an episode
of the polylogs series
thank you for inviting me i thought
maybe the the best place to start would
be to ask you
how
you got interested in computer science
how did you become a computer scientist
yourself
i
have two parents like
i have a father who's a computer
scientist and a mother who's a lawyer so
of course i applied to law school and to
computer science
and i got into both
and i debated and debated
and to this day i cannot tell you what
was the determining factor that made me
choose this i can tell you that my
sister chose the other way and she's a
professor of law so
two girls two different decisions i do
not regret my decision for a moment and
you've also collaborated with your dad
is that right yes but only on a single
paper unfortunately i wish i had done it
more
uh that would have been a joy he was
also my teacher at the hebrew university
which was another wonderful thing
uh he was a phenomenal teacher and i'm
not saying that just because i'm his
daughter he has proof
um with all kinds of student awards and
things like that so it's something that
i can share with him that i think is
very unique for a child to have such an
experience with with a parent
and i'm very happy about it and also
not just that he taught me in those
specific classes but that i can
appreciate the work that he's done the
research that he's done and how
um fundamental and impactful it has been
on all our lives not just mine but the
things that he has done and just one
simple example and there are many many
many more primality testing we need
primes in order to enable cryptography
so without his algorithm which is
basically what's used anywhere
everywhere or most places we wouldn't be
able to enable
uh secure communication and so on so
really a huge impact on everyone's life
and
my sister maybe can understand it at
some level but i can understand it in
another level and really see all the
beauty of all his great ideas that he
had
hmm
um and what was his name i don't know if
he mentioned his name
his name is michael rabin that's how he
says his name but in hebrew it's michael
rabin
right
so to get down to some sort of
fundamental questions just to see where
um it leads us like how would you define
computing or computer science
what is computable
there's the obvious definition right
anything that can be uh computed by a
turing machine
sort of a basic definition
but i think that now we're in a very
very interesting time
with all these things that are happening
in ai of course they're still being
computed by a machine but i think we're
reaching places which
i'm not sure we thought that machines
could do that the algorithms would be
sophisticated enough to really achieve
some goals where it will lead whether
computers will take over humans whether
we will think that interacting with a
computer we're like interacting with our
best friend
i don't know but
uh i think that it's somewhat it's
bringing us to a place where it's not
the
boring definition of what is computed is
what can be computed by a
turing machine but it's something a
little bit more
of what it's offering back to us i think
right
a little bit more ineffable like kind of
you know it's almost
it's almost an intangible it's just
starting to get at that essence of what
you know
yes
yes to be human i guess right right yeah
and i think we're just at the beginning
of that journey and i think it's uh
going to be a fascinating one
it is already fascinating yeah
um and then looking back on the field
how do you
tell the the story what you see is the
arc of
face
so
first of all i think that cryptography
has a fascinating history computer
science of course in general
are very very new
but cryptography has existed since
prehistoric times there were ciphers um
maybe the hieroglyphics or ciphers who
knows caesar cipher and so on and there
were things that had happened all along
over time and of course the enigma
but then in 1976 there was really
a jump
there are things sometimes research
progresses you know one block built on
top of the other but sometimes there's a
jump which really causes a shift in
everything
and that was the paper of diffie and
hellman which introduced basically
ushered in modern day cryptography and
that really was
a meaningful change because cryptography
before this idea of
ideas of odifian hellman required
parties in order to have private
communication required people
to meet in private
maybe for us to talk on the phone maybe
for us to meet in the secret room and
exchange some keying material some
secret data
and then from there on we could continue
to communicate in a secret way even if
we were far apart
but public key cryptography enabled
us to agree on secret king material when
we are far apart when people can be
listening to our com to our
communications this is mind-boggling you
would think how could this happen how
can two people
who are being listened to by a third
party share some secret
and
and first of all it was
amazing that such a thing could happen
but of course it created a huge
opportunity because now secret
communication could really happen
between two people even if they had
never met and this was of course very
important
and
opened a door into this area which is
called modern day cryptography and of
course it's been a flourishing field
since then
and
the nice thing about it is that it
offers things that we need like secrecy
when we're computing
communicating between each other between
two people and we need authentication to
know that i'm speaking to you and you
know you're speaking to me and more of
these fundamental primitives but in fact
it since has gone to unimaginable
things that you can do for example
multi-party computation which was
introduced in the beginning of the 1980s
created a whole area where it's not just
a secret communication between two
people but it's a group of people being
able to compute functions on secret
inputs but still learn the output
for example the simplest question um 10
people are together and they want to
know
the average salary
maybe to figure out they want to know if
they're being discriminated against
so
but nobody wants to reveal their own
salary but they can engage in a
computation that will output just the
average of the compute of the salaries
and that's an amazing tool
and in fact
something that is true about
cryptography in general is that things
are developed mostly in the
sort of academic realm
and it takes time until they're adopted
by the general community and really
utilized
um rsa was designed in 1976
really widespread adoption did not
happen until much later and it happens
with many things like that and sometimes
the necessity from the real world brings
on the adoption and why did i mention
that because for example for multi-party
computation
beautiful theory and a lot of algorithms
that really try to make it practical
that you can use it but then do people
use it
not necessarily but now
with
privacy
legislation
these things are going to become
critical because what does privacy
legislation tell in an organization you
cannot share your data
and sometimes you need you want to
utilize this data in fact for the
benefit of the community
but for the privacy of the individual
the organization is told that they
cannot but two hospitals want to
collaborate and gain some meaningful
information from the data
so now these multi-party computations i
think are going to get a huge boost and
really are going to start to be utilized
because privacy regulation is pushing
this forward and requiring this so i
think this and and it's happened many
times over the history of uh
cryptography that things at the
beginning
were created and only later really um
moved into mainstream
so
i mean i guess that's becoming more and
more or we're seeing that um
right now with covid we have all this
data on our mobile phones and there's
various ways that you know we want to be
tracking people and revealing where they
are how they've tested and so
that may push the
um you know the privacy encryption
applications forward do you think
contact tracing is a very interesting
example
i don't know what to say whether
people will use it or not i think that
what we've also seen is that we're not
good predictors of what people what
bandwagon people want to join and which
ones they don't want to join so i really
can't say
we can see for contact tracing so far
that it really has not caught on though
of course would be a wonderful tool
right
and
use is low and with low use
the
quality of the contact racing is greatly
diminished so
i don't know but it definitely is
bringing things to the attention of
people
and i think okay maybe not contact
tracing but then when some later
multi-party computation privacy
preserving computation comes along
people will have already heard something
in the past maybe in relation to contact
racing maybe it won't be so far and
maybe it could help other things in the
future
whether contact tracing will take off or
not
very hard to say
right yeah
you know why do crypto kitties uh
take off
start being something and other things
just have no traction whatsoever
yeah right
what advancement did you witness over
the course of your career that was most
surprising or startling
well you have to think that modern day
crypto started in 76 and i started
studying in 83 or let's say in 86 i
started buying masters already so
most of the advancement of crypto all
the amazing things have happened uh
during my time
but
uh things that of course i love are the
things that relate more to my specific
research and that's uh an indication of
why i also chose them because i thought
they'd be interesting so multi-party
computations of course was
an advancement that i think
was surprising and exciting and
really created
a host of extremely interesting problems
so that's one thing but of course the
field has gone through
um the introduction of zero knowledge
and that's an unbelievable concept um
pseudorandom
and number generators sort of random
functions uh uh
i can't even semantic security
all these things are all
amazing things that build up these
fields but
the truth is i think of cryptography i'm
sure every researcher thinks that of
their own area but i think that
that they're endless interesting
problems and they re
continuously evolves
and uh i think that there's just a lot
of exciting things to do
and just to give the latest example
which of course has taken the world by
storm not just theory of cryptography as
a research area is cryptocurrencies
right this is built on designs of uh
crypto primitives and it's uh
i don't know how many billion dollar
industry which is just unbelievable so i
think that cryptography because it's
strong connection to our
uh
digital
life uh has a lot of impact you know
maybe more than
complexity not that i want a bad mouth
complexity but just saying that with
something so i think that
um
it's an area that has had many exciting
results and continues to have many
exciting results
uh even the 10 past 10 years have
brought forward fully homomorphic
encryption and obfuscation
uh two things that were developed by
people in my group at ibm
and these things also generated a lot of
excitement a lot of work even in the
past
few months there have been yet
additional
breakthrough results connected to these
things so i think it's an extremely
dynamic field and
um a lot of wonderful things happen
um so what would you consider your own
more most important contribution i mean
i'm sure they've been hard again
probably to single one thing out but
well it's always easy to single one out
because it's your
not that you love your first child more
than your second child but your first
result
is different i say your first child is
opposed to your second because i have
two daughters in case they hear this
interview i don't want them to think
that the first is loved more than the
second but my first result i think will
always be my uh um
most cherished results right and and
what was the technical gist of it
so as i told you there was this area
that had come up of multi-party
computations
uh the first paper
which was um
there were two concurrent ones uh uh
they have been all gold vassal and big
dozen and uh
they had two
similar results that said that in an
information theoretic setting the
theorem was you can compute any
functions with n parties
where at most a third of the parties are
behaving um mis could be misbehaving
might be acting fall in a faulty manner
and the question that was left open was
whether
we could
achieve a higher
fault tolerance whether we could go to a
half it was clear that
half would be a lower bound but whether
we could do it even if um
just below a majority that there's an
honest majority the faulty parties are
less than half whether we could um still
provide the same theorem that any
function can be computed with n parties
where
uh there's only an honest majority and
that was the result of
[Music]
the work
very nice
and i mean looking ahead
what do you find most fascinating or or
worrisome i mean where do you think
things are are going
one thing that i'm very curious to know
but i don't know if things are going
there but this is something that i would
love to know
before i die um whether
we can factor
on a
regular machine not on a quantum machine
so this is something that is just
curiosity i'm not doing anything to
advance this but i would love to know
but this of course brings into uh
into discussion the issue of quantum
computers
because of course if we have quantum
computers then our all our conventional
encryption will be broken because they
rely on a factoring and discrete log
which can be solved easily by a quantum
computer
and that is why the field in fact is
already actively seeking uh designs that
are secure even if a quantum computer
exists and this is something that i
think is very important and has to be uh
efforts have to be invested in and
luckily uh this is happening there are
competitions for
secure schemes
but who knows maybe
we won't have a real quantum computer in
any time soon to break any practical
crypto system that has
a reasonable size key i don't know but i
think that these are important things uh
to look at and i think the field is
looking at it and uh
i think that this sort of
a challenge that might be coming up soon
and needs to be addressed sooner rather
than later of course because once it
happens you're stuck in here
and uh
i think that
somehow the field on its own has this
really good dynamic that things are come
up and new
techniques and ideas and problems
continuously keep arising and i think
for now we're still on a good trend
and the good thing about cryptography is
also why do all the new problems come
about because it really has
a role to play in actual life in what
things need to be solved problems that
are coming for example as i said hipaa
by chance we already had multi-party
computations but all these privacy
legislation they call for the need for
privacy preserving computation so
but they bring in so there's the general
problem say okay i mean multi-party
privacy preserving computations but then
they bring all kinds of interesting
models challenges and so on so really
what's good in the field is that it all
the time
is um has a stream coming in
from real life to try and give
additional things that can be addressed
in the field
so in fact
we have in cryptography what we call
computational functions
and every crypto that we have bar the
one-time pad there is some computational
assumption that we assume that
makes the cryptosystem secure if that
assumption is broken
then
the system will be broken and there will
be no security the issue is that if we
take a
really big number
2048 bit number
that's huge
we have the algorithm but it really
takes a long long time
to compute this so this is what it means
that there is a computational assumption
then in fact
we know how to but it really takes us a
long time
so we make things big enough i won't use
15 for my uh crypto system because it's
small
i'll use uh
as i said a 2048-bit
key
and then it would take a long time to
factor it but quantum computing
computers as i said can compute this in
polynomial time that what we call
computable
efficiently is polynomial time and the
other we say exponential time so quantum
computing computers do have a polynomial
time algorithm for factoring
and
the way that it's done by the way just
specifically about crypto um i had
spoken before about um
uh primality testing
so the way that we get to these very
very long
composites
is
that
we take we choose two prime numbers
and we multiply them really big prime
numbers and we multiply them and what i
had said before about primality testing
we need to know that the two numbers
that we chose are actually prime so
there there is some randomized
algorithm that tells us with very high
probability this number is a prime
and you use two like that
multiply them you get your big composite
and now it's difficult to do the fact
right and what's just to get to the
basics of it so it's a kind of lock and
key relationship like how does that
allow for encryption then
okay so
a rsa which uses such a big composite
which is a product of two primes but now
let's just call it n and what we know is
that it's a product of uh two primes
it has a public key portion
which is n
and then it has a private key portion
and what's the private key it's exactly
those two composites so if i create my
public key i take these two large primes
i multiply them and i publish n
and i publish another
number it can be the number three and
we'll call it e okay equals three could
be some other number but for simplicity
let's call it
and now
the and this goes back to diffie and
helm and this was their great idea that
i can locally publish something
and keep something local but now you can
already encrypt using my public key
using the three and the end you can
compute some function
of the message that you want to send me
and these two values and then you send
it back to me
now i have the private key
the two prime factors of this n
and using them with another function
i can decrypt
so this is why it's very important that
somebody who just hears my n cannot find
the two prime factors because those two
help you decrypt
so this is a private key public key
and the public key in fact can be seen
by anyone but already enables you to
send me a message without anybody being
able to read it anybody who does not
have the secret key and i who have the
prime factorization i can read the
message
got it right thank you
um now you said that
you'd like to know about factorization
before you die but you're not working on
it currently what are you working on
currently yourself
so currently
i am uh
in a
foundation which is called the algorand
which is associated
to a cryptocurrency
called algo
and the
um
the consensus protocol of algorand was
designed by silvio michali
and
introduced a new model
which is a model that says
in in these multi-party computation
settings it says every party only speaks
one
and then it disappears
in all our previous designs
we always said okay we have n parties
and then we engage in a long protocol i
speak you speak they speak i speak again
and so on
but
now this new model says you can only
speak once
so the question is in this new model
where there is this
very hard restriction that you can only
speak once and then you disappear can
you still achieve the multi-party
computation
results that we had in our
um previous model where people could
speak
um as many times as they want so
it's now combining my my new job with my
old love and it's
really nice and in fact we're working on
a paper which we hope will soon be
published
that shows that you in fact can do many
of these multi-party computations only
also in this model which we call yoso
which is you only speak once
fantastic i look forward to seeing it
um well maybe that's a good note to end
on
okay
thank you very much
been wonderful speaking to you
[Music]
you